hey guys now I give a lot of tips on
grooming when it comes to hair and skin
but not so much on teeth so in this
video I'm gonna give you seven mistakes
that most people make when they brush
their teeth what's the full video so
that you'll make sure that you're not
making any of these mistakes let's get
to it
[Music]
the first mistake is not brushing your
teeth long enough how long do you think
you should brush your teeth
1 minute 4 minutes the correct answer is
2 minutes time yourself from today to
make sure you're doing it right and then
you will become a habit over a few days
not brushing your whole mouth now most
people think okay just brush my teeth
right but what about all those germs on
your tongue and the inside of your
cheeks you gotta take care of that as
well
now most toothbrushes got a tongue scrub
on the back so remember to use it
not cleaning between your teeth now
these are the small spaces where food
and bacteria hide and if you use a
normal brush a normal brush is not
really effective to clean between your
teeth so you gotta floss your teeth at
least once a day
using the wrong toothbrush try to stay
away from toothbrushes with hard
bristles soft brushes are always a safe
bet because they won't damage your teeth
or your gums of course you can use an
electric brush or a normal one both will
get the job done but the electric one
will help you a little bit more
brushing your teeth too hard I used to
do this all the time and it's terrible
because you know you want to get your
teeth clean right you brush it but then
you damage your gums and also the enamel
so take it from me be gentle with your
teeth
[Music]
not brushing your teeth enough twice a
day every day not less than that because
then you will get more bacteria tartar
and plague on your teeth and then on the
other hand don't overdo it
because then you can also damage your
gums and
using an awl toothbrush do you know how
old your toothbrush really is can you
even remember when you bought it take a
look at your toothbrush
if the bristles are old and worn out
then it's time to get a new one and then
do you know how long you can use a
toothbrush before you need to replace it
well the a da American Dental
Association recommends three to four
months and then it's time to get a new
one now just a bonus step if you want
your teeth to look whiter
then you need to first of all avoid all
the things that make it yellow like not
brushing your teeth enough smoking and
dark-colored drinks like coffee tea red
wine and cranberry juice and then foods
like Lyman's tomatoes and all kinds of
sugary foods and drinks now I'm not
saying that you should just move away
from everything like everything else in
life you need balance right I love
coffee I'm gonna drink coffee but a good
step is to rinse your mouth out with
water when you're done with the coffee
or any of these other foods or drinks
now if you want some more tips on
grooming style fitness check out some
other videos on my channel and I'll see
you there cheers guys